Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
Je me demande bien à quoi vous
pouvez vous attendre avec ce titre :
« La vie comme une aventure ».
Eh bien, je viens vous parler
d’un loisir particulier,
le jeu de rôle grandeur nature.
C’est une forme de jeu de rôle
où les joueurs et les joueuses
interprètent leur personnage
en immersion, en costume,
dans un événement
qui peut durer un, deux, trois
jusqu’à cinq jours d’affilée pour le
plus long auquel j’ai pu participer.
Vous vous doutez bien que c'est une
expérience particulièrement immersive.
Quand je participe à un de
ces jeux de rôle grandeur nature,
ou GN pour grandeur nature,
comme on dit dans notre jargon,
je suis toujours impressionnée
par l’investissement de toutes et de tous
dans les détails des costumes,
la décoration des campements,
l’énergie et la sincérité mises
dans l’interprétation des personnages.
Chacun et chacune apporte sa petite
pierre à un édifice commun :
une expérience collective inoubliable.
Et inoubliables,
elles le sont, ces expériences.
Je mets en général une ou deux
semaines minimum à m’en remettre.
Il faut dire que
quand on a vécu des intrigues
dignes des meilleures séries télé,
on a vécu des batailles,
des alliances, des trahisons,
c’est un peu difficile
de revenir à la vie normale
et à son boulot derrière un écran.
Autre chose qui m’impressionne
toujours dans les GN,
c’est le nombre incalculable de liens
qui se créent entre les personnages,
mais aussi entre les joueurs
et les joueuses.
En quelques jours de jeu,
je me sens très proche de personnes
que je n’avais jamais vues avant,
avec qui j’ai finalement
peu de points communs,
et j’ai pu constater que ces liens
perdurent avec la distance et le temps,
et certaines de ces personnes sont
devenues des amis très proches.
En tant que professionnelle
de l’accompagnement d’équipe
et particulièrement intéressée
par les dynamiques de groupe,
j’ai eu l’impression
de découvrir là un trésor,
une pépite, quelque chose de magique.
Et je me suis demandé :
« Quels en sont les ingrédients ? »
Si seulement je pouvais trouver
la recette d’une potion magique
qui me permette de retrouver au moins
un petit peu de cette intensité collective
dans mon quotidien.
J’ai participé à plusieurs GN.
J’ai expérimenté et je pense avoir
trouvé quatre ingrédients.
Ce sont ces ingrédients que je suis
venue partager avec vous aujourd’hui.
Mon premier ingrédient,
c’est pouvoir être qui je veux.
J’ai été Elk, la pirate qui fonce dans les
combats pour fuir un passé douloureux.
J’ai été Noëlle, la doyenne guérisseuse
d’une communauté de bergers,
tiraillée entre ses croyances animistes
ancestrales et la peur de l’Inquisition.
J’ai été Thol, la guide vietnamienne
d’une troupe de soldats américains
dans mon pays déchiré
par la guerre civile.
J’ai été Alice Williams, une scientifique
pendant la guerre froide,
réduite au silence dans un asile
pour avoir vu des expériences
qu’elle n’aurait jamais dû voir.
Ou peut-être qu’elle était réellement
psychotique et paranoïaque.
J’ai même été une femme lézard dans un
univers de cape et d’épée fantastique
où les mousquetaires côtoient les dragons.
Il n'y a pas de limite à l'imagination.
Vous ne trouvez pas ça génial, d’avoir
autant de vies dans une seule vie ?
Si seulement je pouvais retrouver
un peu de cette liberté
et de cette diversité au quotidien.
Mais finalement, qu’est-ce
qui m’en empêche ?
Nous avons tous déjà
plusieurs rôles dans la vie.
Je ne suis pas que coach d’équipe,
je ne suis pas que maman,
je ne suis pas qu’intervenante TEDx.
Tous ces rôles sont des casquettes
que j'enfile tour à tour.
Aucune ne me définit complètement
et surtout, aucune ne me limite.
Bien sûr, j’ai des limites,
ce sont mes capacités physiques,
mes compétences, mes connaissances.
Mais à l’intérieur de ces limites,
les possibilités sont déjà infinies.
Par exemple,
quand, il y a cinq mois,
on m’a proposé de faire ce TEDx,
honnêtement,
je ne m’en sentais pas capable.
Mais je pense que ce n’est pas
la bonne question à se poser.
Pour moi, c’est :
est-ce que je suis prête à y consacrer
le temps et l’énergie nécessaires
pour rendre l’interprétation
de ce rôle possible ?
Est-ce que je suis prête à prioriser
et à faire des choix ?
Car malheureusement, les journées
ne sont pas extensibles.
Il se trouve que j'avais
très envie de le faire.
La réponse était oui,
je me suis jetée à l’eau
et voilà, je suis là devant vous ce soir.
Donc, c'est bien la preuve pour moi
que je peux être qui je veux.
Mon deuxième ingrédient
va me permettre de vivre
des émotions fortes en toute sécurité.
Un GN, c’est beaucoup d’émotions fortes.
Il y a le frisson des batailles,
il y a la douleur du deuil,
il y a la chaleur du réconfort
des membres de son clan.
Ces scènes ne sont pas posées,
les joueurs et les joueuses improvisent,
complètement en immersion
dans leur personnage.
La plupart du temps, ils ne savent
même pas qu’ils sont photographiés.
Et je peux vous garantir que même
si l’émotion paraît difficile à vivre,
chacun et chacune est en train de passer
un excellent moment de jeu.
Comment est-ce que c’est possible ?
Eh bien, c’est possible
grâce à un ingrédient magique
c’est la sécurité émotionnelle.
La sécurité de toutes et de tous
est une préoccupation majeure pour tous
les organisateurs et participants de GN.
Il y a la sécurité physique,
ça, c’est assez facile à expliquer.
Nous utilisons ce type d'accessoire,
c'est du latex.
Il est quasiment impossible
de se faire mal avec ce type d’épée.
Même si elle peut être
impressionnante en combat.
Et pour la sécurité émotionnelle, alors ?
Comment se protéger d’une émotion ?
Au même titre que nous avons
des armes en latex,
est-ce que nous pourrions avoir
des émotions en mousse ?
Je pense que oui.
Prenez par exemple la situation
où vous êtes en train
de regarder un film à suspense.
Il peut vous arriver de retenir
involontairement votre respiration,
voire de sursauter.
L’émotion est réelle,
puisque vous la vivez,
et pourtant, elle ne vous fait pas mal.
Elle n’est pas dangereuse,
voire vous pouvez la rechercher un peu,
sinon, on ne regarderait pas
ce genre de film.
Eh bien, pour moi, les émotions en GN,
c’est un peu la même chose,
mais puissance mille, parce que je ne suis
pas dans mon canapé devant un écran,
je suis dans le film, j’interprète
un des personnages de l’histoire.
Les émotions sont donc
beaucoup plus fortes.
Nous avons donc besoin
de quelques techniques et astuces
pour nous en protéger.
Il en existe plusieurs, mais celle que je
suis venue partager avec vous ce soir,
c’est une sorte de petite
gymnastique intellectuelle
qui consiste à faire la différence
entre mes émotions
et les émotions de mon personnage
qui sont liées à mon rôle.
C’est ce qui va me permettre
d’être au même moment
en train de jouer sincèrement un
personnage qui pleure la mort d’un proche
et d’être consciente,
exactement au même moment,
de vivre un super moment de jeu, un cadeau
dont je me rappellerai toute ma vie.
Et dans la vraie vie, alors ?
J’ai commencé à essayer de faire pareil,
voir si ça avait un intérêt de séparer
mes émotions entre moi et mes rôles.
Je dois vous dire que je trouve ça très,
très utile en contexte professionnel.
Si vous êtes dans une réunion par exemple,
que quelque chose commence à vous agacer -
je pense que cela nous est tous arrivé -
c’est assez facile de se dire
que cette émotion négative-là,
plutôt que de la laisser m’emporter,
elle est liée à mon rôle professionnel,
elle est légitime,
mais il n’y a aucune raison qu’elle
me pourrisse la vie personnellement.
Ça, c'est pour les émotions négatives.
Mais il y a mieux encore,
c’est pour les émotions positives.
Parce que ce petit recul par rapport
à mes émotions m’oblige à les regarder,
à en prendre conscience.
Ça veut dire que quand je suis en train
de vivre un excellent moment,
je suis consciente au moment où je le vis.
Je ne suis pas simplement en train
de me construire des beaux souvenirs.
Mon troisième ingrédient
va vous parler de collectif.
Un GN, c’est forcément
une expérience collective.
Pour moi, il y a peu de sens à interpréter
parfaitement un personnage,
si ce n'est pas en interaction
avec les autres.
Je vais donc revenir sur cette notion
essentielle de la sécurité émotionnelle,
mais du point de vue du collectif.
Et pour ça, je vais vous raconter
une petite histoire.
J’étais à un GN - encore -
et j’interprétais Noëlle,
la guérisseuse
d’une communauté de bergers.
Pendant le jeu, une des joueuses -
en tout cas son personnage -
vient me voir en tant que guérisseuse
en me disant qu’elle a mal au ventre.
Donc je commence à mimer un examen.
Et à ce moment-là,
il y a un organisateur qui était
discrètement présent dans la scène,
qui me glisse à l’oreille que
ce n’est pas un simple mal de ventre.
Je vais découvrir à l’issue
de l’examen qu’elle est enceinte.
C’est sûrement quelque chose qui avait
un intérêt pour les organisateurs, ok.
Je finis mon examen
et j’annonce à la joueuse,
au personnage en face de moi :
« Ce n’est pas un mal de ventre.
Félicitations, tu es enceinte ! »
Et là, je ne saurais pas dire
exactement à quel signe,
mais j’ai senti que ce n’était pas ok,
que la joueuse en face de moi
ne le vivait pas bien.
Donc j’ai fait ce signe -
ça, le poing levé.
Pour nous, en tant que GNiste,
pratiquant de GN,
ce signe-là, ça veut dire
qu’on met le jeu en pause.
À ce moment-là, ce que je vais dire,
ce n’est pas Noëlle la guérisseuse
qui s’adresse au personnage,
c’est moi, Élodie, en tant que joueuse
qui parle à la joueuse,
tout le reste est en pause.
Et je lui demande si elle est d’accord,
si ça lui pose problème ou pas
de jouer le fait d’être enceinte.
Est-ce que le thème de la maternité
est OK pour elle ?
La réponse était non.
Et à partir de là,
peu importe ce qui était prévu,
pas besoin de justification,
la sécurité émotionnelle de la joueuse
passe en premier.
On a changé, c’était un simple
mal de ventre, et voilà.
Ce que cette anecdote illustre pour moi,
c’est que la sécurité émotionnelle,
ce n'est pas simplement une histoire
de vigilance personnelle.
C’est un enjeu collectif
parce que quand on commence à être
impacté par nos propres émotions,
on est rarement les mieux placés
pour s’en rendre compte et pour réagir.
Cette attention les uns aux autres,
cette vigilance collective,
ça crée, je trouve, en GN
une atmosphère particulière.
Quand j’arrive en GN, je sais que,
quelles que soient les horreurs qu’on
va se dire de personnage à personnage -
et franchement, des fois,
ce n’est pas tendre -
il y aura toujours
cette vigilance collective
et la conscience que,
derrière le personnage, derrière le rôle,
il y a quelqu’un, un être humain et qu’on
doit faire attention les uns aux autres.
Vous ne trouveriez pas ça génial
si, dans la vraie vie,
il y avait un petit peu plus
de cette attention les uns aux autres ?
Moi, je pense que si, que ça rendrait
la vie un peu plus douce.
Donc, je décide,
avec mon troisième ingrédient,
d’être consciente de l’impact
que j’ai sur les autres.
Mes paroles, mes gestes, l’expression de
mes émotions ont un impact sur les autres
et j’ai une responsabilité
dans la gestion de la situation.
Par exemple,
si je suis en situation de conflit,
j’ai une personne en face de moi,
on n’est pas d’accord.
J’avance mes arguments,
il avance ses arguments, le ton monte.
Si je vois qu’elle se laisse
emporter par ses émotions,
même si moi je sens que c’est le cas,
qu’est-ce qui m’empêche
de mettre la conversation en pause ?
Je ne vais pas forcément lever le poing
car il ne saura pas ce que cela veut dire,
mais en tout cas sortir du contexte
pour se rappeler que,
quels que soient nos différends
et les arguments qu’on peut continuer
à avancer, même avec véhémence,
on se respecte en tant qu’êtres humains.
Quatrième ingrédient.
C’est une histoire,
et si possible, une belle histoire.
Il y a quelque chose qui étonne toujours
quand je parle de GN
à des personnes qui ne connaissent pas,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas
de scénario pré-écrit.
Il n’y a pas d’histoire
qui soit contrôlée.
Bien sûr, les organisateurs
peuvent définir un univers,
une situation de départ, des personnages.
Pendant le jeu, ils peuvent faire des
événements qui vont influencer l’histoire,
mais globalement, à partir du moment
où le jeu commence,
l’histoire est hors de contrôle
puisque tout le monde improvise.
Donc, personne ne contrôle l’histoire.
Il n’y a pas de scénario
et il y a mieux que ça :
non seulement personne ne la contrôle,
mais personne ne la connaît complétement.
Dans un GN, nous sommes nombreux.
20, 30, c’est un petit GN.
A partir de 100 participants,
on commence à parler de grand GN,
de plusieurs centaines,
voire de milliers -
le plus grand d’Europe rassemble
5 000 participants en Allemagne.
Vous vous doutez qu’il est impossible
d’assister à toutes les conversations
et de savoir qui a fait
une alliance avec untel, etc.
Donc personne ne connaît
et ne connaîtra jamais toute l’histoire.
Et pourtant elle existe.
Et quand je vais à un GN,
je suis consciente
d’être en train de construire
une belle aventure, une belle histoire
collectivement.
Une histoire que personne
ne contrôle complètement
et que personne ne connaît en entier,
dont personne ne connaît la fin,
ça ne ressemblerait pas
un peu à la vraie vie ?
Je pense que si.
Gandalf, ce sage Gandalf, nous dit
que tout ce que nous devons décider,
c’est que faire du temps
qui nous est imparti.
C’est assez simple,
on a une décision à prendre.
Eh bien, moi, je décide, dans mes choix,
de vivre avec vous une grande aventure.
Comment on fait en GN
pour savoir comment faire ?
Vu qu’il n’y a pas de scénario, je ne
sais pas quelle action je dois jouer.
La consigne est simple :
jouer la scène que vous aimeriez
voir en tant que spectateur.
N'hésitez pas à surjouer.
Eh bien, dans la vraie vie,
pourquoi ne pas jouer la scène comme
si nous étions les personnages d’un film,
voir la scène qu’on aimerait voir en tant
que spectateur, créer de belles scènes ?
Car l’assemblage de belles scènes
ferait une belle histoire.
Et ce n’est pas parce que
je ne la vois pas qu’elle n’existe pas.
Je pense qu’il est plus important
de jouer la scène que nous voudrions voir
que de servir nos propres intérêts,
de même que dans un GN,
c’est plus important
que les intérêts d’un personnage.
C’est ça qui va créer
cette histoire collective.
On pourrait croire qu’on y perd,
individuellement,
mais je suis persuadée qu’on y gagne,
car cette histoire collective,
elle nous dépasse,
mais elle nous unit et elle pourrait
même donner un sens à notre vie.
Donc, voilà mes quatre ingrédients.
Je peux être qui je veux.
Je peux vivre des émotions fortes
en toute sécurité,
avec une vigilance sur moi-même, mais
aussi en faisant attention aux autres.
Et enfin, je ne veux pas juste
qu’on vive ensemble,
je veux vivre une grande
aventure avec vous.
Voilà ma potion magique.
Qui veut la goûter ?
(Applaudissements)